this video is brought to you by
squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business check out squarespace
through the link in the description
below we've got more on them in just a
bit
ask anyone to name one fact about
william howard taft and you'll likely
get a reply along the lines of it was so
fat that he got stuck in a bathtub right
today the 27th president exists only as
an amusing anecdote a punchline to a
joke about overeating even those who are
aware the bathtub story is false tend to
know little else about him sandwiched
between the active presidencies of teddy
roosevelt and woodrow wilson taft's one
term can seem like little more than just
the pause in the story of america's
progressive era and that is a terrific
shame because william taft was more than
just a waistline on a human level he was
arguably one of the most fascinating
presidents born to an over-achieving
family tapped at a cv that few others
could dream of first civilian governor
of the philippines professional governor
of cuba and the only man to ever serve
as both president and chief justice yet
he still spent his life haunted by a
profound
fear of failure today we're
investigating the life of william howard
taft one of america's most overlooked
presidents
[Music]
when william howard taft was born in
cincinnati ohio on september 15 1857 it
was into a family for which the term
high achievers was a absolute
understatement his father alfonso was a
lawyer who'd go on to serve as secretary
of war and attorney general under
president ulysses s grant and also
ambassador to austria-hungary under
chester arthur and was it just his dad
who was doing great things taft's two
older brothers from his father's first
marriage would go to yale and then into
blisteringly successful careers later
siblings would be lawyers and founders
of private schools amid all of this
excellence taft would have a hard time
sticking out yet the future president
never had to work to get anyone's
attention from the earlier stage the
entire family were convinced
that he was destined for great things
quite why they thought this is something
of a mystery although it was extremely
bright and in possession of a sharp mind
taft wasn't a once-in-a-generation
prodigy he was clever he was good at
baseball but you know
sir a lot of people but where taft
really shines was his ability to get
along with everybody genial
self-deprecating and by all accounts
genuinely warm-hearted to outpersonalize
people who could walk into a room full
of enemies and leave five minutes later
with a new set of best friends at school
he was popular at home he was his mom's
favorite his dad's favorite even his
siblings favorite in later life older
brother charlie would donate a quarter
of his income to helping taft get ahead
but while this might sound like the
perfect recipe for creating added title
bad baby it taff's case the exact
opposite happened placed on a pedestal
told he had greatness within him and
pushed to succeed taft instead seemed to
have doubted a deep neurosis about not
living up to expectations all his life
he would be haunted by anxiety forever
dealing with an internal critic that
whispered in his ear that he's not good
enough that he was somehow disappointing
everybody it even been suggested that
his well-documented struggles with
overeating were a coping mechanism a way
of dealing with the poison of
expectations gnawing away at his soul
still
for all he may have been privately
tormented taft was publicly a guy living
the dream at yale he graduated second in
his class before studying law and
passing the bar at the age of 23. from
there he took up a post as an assistant
prosecutor in hamilton county soon
becoming a respected member of a higher
society it was also at this time that he
discovered his two great loves the first
was the law from the earliest days of
his career and more so after he was
appointed judge on the cincinnati
superior court taft was head over heels
for the legal system as he explained
many years later i love judges and i
love courts they are my ideals that
typify on earth what we shall meet
hereafter in heaven andrew just god his
second great love though was far less
abstract and far more human helen herron
known to everyone as nelly was the exact
sort of hyper-ambitious match taft's
family felt he deserved a woman whose
father had worked for president hayes
and his soul now burned to do something
of consequence had she been born a
century later it's likely nellie would
have run for office but living in an era
when women voting was the punchline to
unfunny jokes she was forced instead to
realize her dreams through her husband's
after the bear wed in 1886 nelly slotted
right into taft's family another voice
forever encouraging him to do better to
go further to be the great man that he
was destined to be so sure were they all
of taft's future success that they took
career decisions for him planning his
next moves how he could keep climbing
all the way to the very top for his part
taft seemed to have been willing to do
whatever they decided howardly he was
content to just be the vessel for his
family's hopes and dreams but it would
take someone else to push taft to the
pinnacle someone from outside the family
a man with the exact sort of boundless
energy the boy from ohio needed in his
life a man known as theodore roosevelt
[Music]
if you'd visited washington in the early
1890s you might have bumped in to not
one but two future presidents out for a
stroll the beginning of the decade had
seen taft summon to the capital to take
up the prestigious boast of solicitor
general there he'd made friends with the
young civil service commissioner from
new york now the two of them were in the
habit of walking past the grand
buildings together dreaming about where
their careers might take them supposedly
teddy roosevelt liked to go via the
white house where he'd gesture and
declare that this would be his future
home for his part it said that taft
preferred walking by the supreme court
the ultimate destination for a man now
rising through the judiciary we say
supposedly because there's a minor
problem with this story the supreme
court building didn't yet exist in the
1890s the justices still met in the
capitol building still you know it's a
nice anecdote and one that displays
their two friends very different
personalities teddy roosevelt the big
dreamer who craved the limelight and
william taft the judge who preferred to
work quietly in the shadows little could
the pair have known that both their
dreams were soon gonna come true but
that's for future chapters for now let's
simply follow taft as he takes a job on
the sixth circuit court of appeals as he
settles into the life that he always
wanted as a respected judge dealing with
meaningful cases finale though this was
an irritating time a time when she felt
that her husband was not only stagnating
but happily stagnating a time when her
own flame of ambition one society didn't
allow her to tend herself
was in danger of
flickering out luckily she wasn't the
only one who felt taft should set his
sights higher in 1900 a telegram landed
on taft's desk summoning him to see the
president at that time that president
was william mckinley a guy with the
formal clothes and weird dark-eyed stare
of lurch and uncle festa's secret love
child more importantly he was also a
fellow ohioan a fellow ahayan he knew
the taft family and now had a job for
its beloved son he wanted william to
become the philippines first civilian
governor back in 1898 spain had
suicidally declared war in america
resulting in the quick loss of its last
remnants of empire in the aftermath the
philippine islands had been handed to
the united states however the filipinos
kind of felt like the islands should
belong to you know
them and they launched an insurrection
the american response
as to unleash hell under general
macarthur father of the way more famous
douglas macarthur u.s troops raised
villages shot prisoners and tortured
locals the result was a brutalized
country wasted by conflict it was into
this inferno that mckinley wanted to
have to go for someone used to the quiet
life of a judge the offer was about as
appetizing as a soup starter of cold dog
vomit a taft been single he likely would
have declined but taff wasn't single and
nelly knew an opportunity when she saw
one knocking at her insistence taff took
the posting relocating with her halfway
around the world it could have been a
disaster an uninterested man taking on a
vitally important job that he wished he
didn't have to do
but here's the thing about william
howard taft he never did anything
half-assed he was here to improve things
in the philippines that was exactly what
he was going to do as civilian governor
taft ended macarthur's reign of terror
humanizing u.s policy towards its new
colony to constitution model on the u.s
bill of rights the establishment of a
civil service in new hospitals the
distribution of land to peasants via
low-cost mortgages while taft was a huge
improvement over macarthur he was still
an imperialist at heart one who believed
filipinos were incapable of governing
themselves the islands wouldn't be
granted independence until
1946 of course taft would be long gone
by then in 1904 he received another
telegram demanding that he returned in
washington only this time he would be
serving under president mackenzie but
under his closest friend you know what's
great about the summer vacation time off
a little bit of r r is the perfect time
to spend a little time on the beach
daydreaming about that next project that
you want to start well fortunately
squarespace gives you every possible
tool you might want to start that new
project whether it's a small business a
sports blog a creative portfolio or just
a page full of dank memes it does not
matter if you can dream it you can build
it with squarespace you look to get in
and out quick without thinking too much
about what your website should look like
bam use one of their quick beautiful
templates to make a website that's fresh
and for you or maybe you're more of a
hands-on person you've got lots of
opinions and ideas about what exactly
your site should look like well
squarespace gives you all the
customization options you could ever
want with no updates no patches no
technical bs to worry about and once
you're done setting up your website
tinkering with the design if you're so
inclined or maybe just playing around
with the colors there are so many extra
features that squarespace provides so
your site can thrive email campaigns
patronage portals social integrations
member-only areas analytics commercial
options focus on customer support
everything you need is really in one
place so when you're ready to get
started the next project of yours big or
small if it involves a website you've
got to do it with squarespace go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com biographics to save 10
of your first purchase of a website or a
domain
and let's get back to today's video
for a guy that no one's ever heard of
garrett hobart sure had an outsized
impact on u.s history mckinley's first
vice president hobart managed to die of
heart disease just a year before
mckinley stood for re-election that's
important because prior to the 25th
amendment it was standard practice for
the vice presidency to remain vacant if
a told or died had hobart croaked a year
later there would have been no vp in
place when mckinley was assassinated in
september 1901 but because hobart died
prior to the 1900 election it meant
mckinley was able to put a new vp on his
ticket a vp
who would step in when mckinley was
killed becoming one of the most dynamic
presidents in u.s history and teddy
roosevelt's sudden ascension to the
white house would in turn change the
course of william tapp's life from the
moment he became head honcho roosevelt
tried to coax his old friend back to
washington offering taft a seat on the
supreme court twice both times taft
turned him down unwilling to abandon the
philippines at such a crucial time in
1904 though teddy finally did a
godfather making the old man an offer
that he couldn't refuse
to become the secretary of war the nelly
charlie and taft's family this was the
moment they dreamed of the moment when
william would embrace the greatness
within and become one of the most
important men in america taftu was on
board roosevelt had promised him that he
could continue to monitor the
philippines from his new posting and so
it was that taft returned to washington
that same year just in time to witness
teddy win a grand victory in the
november election securing a full term
of his own it was in the afterglow of
this win that roosevelt made the speech
that would transform taft's life having
already served most of mckinley's second
term and with his own term now ahead of
him roosevelt publicly promised not to
stand again in 1908 and spoiler alert
that promise is why you're now watching
a video on william taft the 27th
president and not on half the random
dude who is friends with teddy roosevelt
and speaking of that friendship these
were the heydays between old bill and
bull moose an era oh and the two were
virtually inseparable from his position
in the cabinet taft became roosevelt's
right-hand man supervising the building
of the panama canal acting as a
provisional governor to cuba and
traveling the world to promote american
interests more importantly though he
also deployed his legendary charm like a
weapon winning over anyone who might
stand in the way of roosevelt's
ambitious program and ambitious it
certainly was this was the peak of the
progressive era an age of muscular
reform that began with mckinley and
would end with world war one and
roosevelt and taft were its perfect
prophets on the one hand you had
roosevelt's boundless energy sharp
instincts and willingness to lead his
nation in previously unthinkable
directions on the other hand you had
taft's discreet charm and legalistic
mind able to win around people who might
otherwise be intimidated by the bull
moose in fact their partnership was so
effective but when 1908 rolled around
and roosevelt upheld his promise not to
run again there was only one obvious
replacement well it was obvious to
roosevelt at least the problem was that
taft absolutely did not want to be
president like he couldn't think of a
job that he was possibly less suited for
but roosevelt cajoled him
him and charlie cajoled him and well you
know
taft ended up doing what he always did
he let others shape his destiny although
the election was technically a match
between taft and democrat william
jennings bryan it was really a
referendum on whether americans wanted
another four years of roosevelt while
taft barely campaigned teddy traveled
the country letting everyone know taft
would continue his policies and for most
voters that was all they needed to hear
that november the republicans netted a
solid win on march the 4th 1909 william
taft was sworn in as the 27th president
but if voters were expecting another
four years of teddy roosevelt they were
going to be sorely disappointed because
once in office taft was going to abandon
his progressive roots and drift slowly
into conservatism in doing so he'd
nearly condemn the republican party to
annihilation
with taft now installed in the white
house we can finally begin discussing
what he did and didn't do our president
which is useful because there's one
thing he absolutely didn't do that has
nonetheless gone down an infamy
president taft he never got stuck in a
bathtub the origins of this rumor aren't
hard to imagine taft remains the most
obese person to ever be president
topping out at over 300 pounds in part
due to his eating a dozen eggs and a
pound of bacon every morning while today
we're more likely to see his chronic
overeating through the lens of his
anxiety for people in 1908 it was just
something to laugh at a typical joke ran
tapped as the most polite man in
washington one day gave up a seat on a
streetcar to three women with jokes like
that it's easy to see how an unkind
rumor about bathtubs might have got
started but we shouldn't go feeling
sorry for taft for the awesome reason
that the man himself seemingly didn't
give the tiniest mouse turd or where his
waistline was also a punchline to have
to owned it refusing to be remotely
ashamed of his girth if you made a joke
about his weight taft would make one
right back one of his favorites was to
recount boasting to a co-worker that had
spent all day riding horseback only for
his co-worker to inquire
and how's the horse combined with taps
easy charm these self-deprecating
remarks turned his way from ammo for his
enemies to just another part of his
really genial personality it's easy to
forget now that he sunk into obscurity
that these moments why some voters
really did love taft his playfulness
like starting the tradition of
presidents throwing the ceremonial first
pitch in major league baseball of course
they didn't love him enough to give him
a second term though the story behind
why is the dark flip side to this little
digression the somber serious side they
saw everything
go horribly wrong the catastrophes came
in both taft's personal and professional
lives on the personal side nelly
suffered a devastating stroke shortly
after the election though she survived
and eventually recovered taft was forced
to care for her tapping his energy but
the bigger problem was taft's inability
to lib up to roosevelt's legacy in the
beginning things went well to have
followed his predecessor's cue on trust
busting launching nearly 100
prosecutions and smashing up oil tobacco
sugar and even porcelain price-fixing
rings soon though the mistakes began to
pile up although a trustbuster roosevelt
believed there were certain good trusts
including u.s steel when taft went after
them teddy accused him of lacking
intelligence taft was so stung by the
criticism that he wound up swinging too
far the other way switching trust
busting for a cozy relationship with the
party's pro-business wing nor was it
just where the trusts were concerned
that taft fumbled his mentor's legacy
during his presidency roosevelt had
issued a flurry of executive orders on
conservation bypassing congress to
quickly protect the nation's wilderness
but taft's legal background made him
squeamish about presidential decree so
he tried to get congress to pass
roosevelt's orders properly the problem
was that many of them were effectively
suspended as they went through both
chambers this gave the impression that
taft was backpedaling on roosevelt's
beloved conservation efforts an
impression reinforced when taft fired
teddy's guy in the forest service
finally there's the issue of tariffs in
this era the progressive roosevelt wing
of the republican party was obsessed
with tariff reform calling it the mother
of all trusts the assumption was that
taft would continue teddy's work on the
issue instead he wound up supporting a
woefully compromised bill one plagued by
so many amendments it was effectively
useless by now the gop's roosevelt wing
was effectively in revolt against the
new president nor were they alone across
the seas the man who'd put taft in the
white house was watching his performance
with cold and unimpressed eyes before
long the bull moose would have taken it
upon himself to come back and sort
things out and when he did it was going
to be game over for the 27th president
in 9010 teddy roosevelt returned to new
york from africa to find something like
a gazillion people waiting for him it
was the sort of ego boost that would
make anyone big-headed and in
roosevelt's case it convinced him the
public were crying out for him to retake
the white house and so began the slow
motion battle between the two old
friends for the 1912 nomination on the
sidelines teddy fired off broadside
after broadside taking taft task for
ignoring progressive policies the he did
this the more conservative taft became
and the angrier at his old friend he got
finally in april 1912 taft finally seems
that
he'd had enough with teddy ready to run
against him the 27th president made a
speech where he declared re-electing
roosevelt would be like making
robespierre president that his old
friend
was going to unleash a reign of terror
and this as you might imagine was the
moment that the gloves came off between
the two men sadly the subsequent
bare-knuckle fight would only succeed
in koi'ing both of them that spring and
summer the primary battle were uglier
and uglier with teddy dominating the
states that held direct primaries while
taft scored big in those where patronage
and party machinery still held sway it
all culminated in a bitter convention in
chicago where rival slates of delegates
for taft and roosevelt literally fought
to claim their seats there were
fistfights people threatened with
baseball bats one man
even drew a gun in the end though taft
had something his former friend didn't
control of the body chooses which
delegates to seat when taf's guys were
chosen roosevelt and his delegates
stormed out decamping across town they
formed a brand new party the progressive
party better known as the bulmu's party
and so ended any shot william taft ever
had at retaining the presidency the
electorate that year was just not really
interested in the sort of cautious
conservative that to have to become they
wanted an active president a progressive
who'd shake up the system and fight for
them with both teddy roosevelt and
democratic challenger woodrow wilson
fighting for the progressive mantle taft
was simply relegated to the shadows he
just was there watching hopelessly as
his campaign failed to splutter to life
the results that november were worse
than taft could have feared with a lowly
23.2 percent of the popular vote he
carried a grand total of two states the
last time either the republicans or
democrats had placed third in a
presidential election but while
roosevelt may have steamrolled his
former friend it was a pyrrhic victory
when the bulmer's parties 27.4 was
announced it became immediately clear
that all teddy roosevelt had achieved
was splitting the republican vote united
around woodrow wilson the democrats
cruised to an electoral college
landslide faced with a bitter defeat
taft didn't even try to spin things
referring to the result as not only a
landslide but a tidal wave and holocaust
all rolled into a general cataclysm as
the end of his time the white house the
end of his time as an elected official
of well any sort yet it wasn't the end
of taft the man even as he left
washington under a cloud of ignominity
he was already on the path to achieving
his greatest dream
[Music]
once he left the white house taft was
fond of declaring that he didn't miss
politics in the slightest but that
didn't mean politics had forgotten him
as the wilson years gave way to world
war one and then a devastating recession
the shine came off the progressive era
in the 1920 election republican warren g
harding won a something victory by
campaigning for a return to normalcy
odo's first act was to bring another
conservative back in from the cold in
1921 harding offered to have to seat on
the supreme court taft agreed on the
condition that he could be his boss that
july taft was sworn in as chief justice
of the united states the first person to
ever had both the judicial and the
executive branches of government it was
also likely the first time that he was
fulfilling his own career dreams rather
than those of someone else this may be
why as chief justice taft was far more
consequential than he'd ever be as
president and well that started with the
supreme court building i remember
earlier how we mentioned the court met
in some basement in the capital while
that had been bugging taft for years
here were two branches of government
legislative and executive each with
their own grandiose seats of power so
well why shouldn't the judiciary get one
of those as well taft's reasoning was
that a great building would demonstrate
in stone what the constitution said that
the three branches were co-equal and he
had to fight for it but eventually
people agreed and while taft wouldn't
live long enough to see the building
completed it would still stand as his
greatest legacy there were other major
changes taft made that likewise helped
create the modern supreme court the
first was to get rid of an automatic
right of appeal allowing the court to
ditch its five-year backlog and focus
his energies on important constitutional
questions the second was to emphasize
the profound importance of unity taft
firmly believed the court's legitimacy
came from being above partisan politics
to that end he felt dissent should be
recorded as rarely as possible in his
nine years as chief justice 84 of all
rulings were unanimous he himself only
issued four written dissents one of them
when the court struck down the right
female workers to claim minimum wage
that's not to say the taft court was a
perfect record of course cautiously
conservatives the last taft wound up
overseeing rulings that seem a bit
absurd today such as asserting the
legality of prohibition or blocking
congress from tackling child labor still
it's worth pointing out one inaugural
positive of this time it seems that taft
was at last
truly happy
partly that may be because he managed to
make up with teddy roosevelt before the
ball moves died in 1918 the two old
frenemies bumped into one another in a
hotel rather than dredge up the past
they simply hugged sat down for a drink
declaring that it was good to see each
other but mostly it may have been that
taft was at last doing the job that had
been born to do william howe tapped
retired from the supreme court on
february 3 1930. barely a month later on
march the 8th he was dead from a heart
disease he was 72. today taft is one of
the little remembered presidents joining
guys like calvin coolidge who history
nerds find fascinating but the general
public has just broadly forgotten about
certainly there's a good argument that
his presidency was a bit of a nothing
burger neither as celebrated as
roosevelt or as consequential and
certainly controversial as woodrow
wilson's and we'd be lying if we said we
hadn't developed something of a soft
spot for him while making this video he
was a kind man an intelligent man with
the misfortune to spend half of his life
haunted by anxiety by the specter that
he was letting those around him down
that's why it's so heartwarming to read
the words of journalist william ellenboy
to saw him in action at the supreme
court finally doing the job he loved as
why noted taft at that moment appeared
like one of the high gods of the world a
smiling buddha placid wise gentle and
sweet in other words the man
that it always wanted to be
[Music]
you